اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في سعه الاخباريه مفصله
من العربيه نبداها بالعناوين
معارك عنيفه بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع اعمده الدخان وذوي انفجارات في
محيط القصر الجمهوري
المؤسسات الصحيه تنهار في غرب دارفور
ونقابه اطباء السودان تطالب بفتح ممرات
امنه
مجلس التعاون الخارجي يؤكد ان الاعتداء
على المقارب الدبلوماسيه سيزيد مخاطرا
فيلات الوضع في السودان
وفي اخبارنا ايضا
روسيا تحدد الولايات المتحده بتدابير
عسكريه اذا استخدمت اراضي فنلندا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
المباشره والمتواصله على شاشه العربيه
للحرب في السودان منذ ساعات الاولى لصباح
اليوم بدات المواجهه تشتد بين الجيش
والدعم السريع خاصه في محيط القصف
الجمهوري في الخرطوم حيث تتصاعد اعمده
الدخان في محيط القصر الجيش السوداني
استخدم في المعارك الطيران الحربي فيما
استعانت قوات الدعم السريع بمضادات
الطيران مصادر العربيه حدثت في هذا السياق
عن محاوله الجيش السوداني التقدم نحو
القصر الجمهوري وسط مقاومه من الدعم
السريع
لازم اشتغل يعني في في
السلع في زياده يعني اي حاجه لازم انا
اشتغل
لي زي ساعتين ثلاثه وقف لانه البلد ما
امنا
فيه ولا ما في
لازم واحد تخاطر بنفسه يحاول يشتغل القواد
ما حبابه والخوف
[موسيقى]
هذا ونشر الجيش صور لضبط مخازن اسلحه قال
انها تابعه لقوات الدعم السريه تحتوي على
الاف الذخائر
مخازن
تحت الفرش مخازن اوروبيه تحت
الدولارات
الخير خاصه للدعم السريع تركوها
تحت الدول المخازن الارضيه تحت الجبل
مخزن عملاق
كبير جدا جدا
مؤلفه من الذخائر
في الاثناء لا تزار الاتهامات متبادله
بشان من خلق الهدنه اولا بيان للجيش حمل
قوه دعم السريعه المسؤوليه لخرق الهدنه في
الاحياء السكنيه البيان اشار الى وقوع
اعمال نهب للبنوك والمحلات التجاريه في
محيط السد الهلال
لافتا الى هروب اعداد كبيره من قوه الدعم
السريع من اندرمان باتجاه الغرب وقال
الجيش ان السفير الهند في الخرطوم ابلغ عن
اقتحام السفاره وسرقه ممتلكاتها
ورغم اعلان جنوب السودان موافقه اطراف
الصراع في السودان على وقف اطلاق النار
لمده اسبوع اعتبار من يوم غد الخميس قال
يوسف عزت مستشار حميتي العربيه ان قوات
دعم لم توافق بعد على الهدنه كما اكد
مستشار حميه ان قوات الدعم السريع لا ترفض
الهدى في حال ضمير الالتزام بها متهمًا في
الوقت ذاته الجيش السوداني بخرقها
اذا لم يستطع البرهان
وما زلنا نحن اليوم نعيش هدنه معلنه
والطيران يخطف المدنيين ويقصف مواقعنا
لم يتم الالتزام بكل هذه الهدن فمن السابق
لاوانه
لمده اسبوع تبدا بعد نهايه هذه الهدنه نحن
نتعامل مع قوه
وافقنا على هدى بواسطه امريكا بواسطه
السعوديه لم يتم الالتزام على بالهدنه ليس
لدينا مانع في هدى جديده لكن لابد ان تكون
هنالك جهه ما تقول من خلق الهدنه
مقترح هدنه وموافقه ثنائيه وعهود
بالالتزام ومن ثم ترحيب دولي سيناريو
متطابق تكرر 6 مرات على مدار اسبوعين في
السودان دائما ما ينتهي بالطريقه ذاتها
دون اي نتائج مرجوه مع تبادل طرفي الصراع
الاتهامات بخلقها
اولى المحاولات كانت يوم الثامن عشر من
ابريل لمده 24 ساعه ليتم خرقها باشتباكات
في الخرطوم وهي وليده ساعات اما الثانيه
هدنه قصيره المدى لمده 24 ساعه انتهت قبل
ان تبدا بالطريقه ذاتها التي انتهت فيها
الاولى
هي اول هدنه تمتد لثلاثه ايام طوال ايام
عيد الفطر او كما يفترض ذلك انتهت
باشتباكات متفرقه
تمديد للسابقه لمده 72 ساعه في يومي
الخامس والعشرين والسابع والعشرين من
ابريل تم تعب ببساطه امريكيه لكن
الانفجارات والاشتباكات استمرت خلالهما
واجهت مصاعب قبل تطبيقها حتى فالاشتباكات
كانت تدور جنوبي الخرطوم مع تحليق لسلاح
الجو السوداني ورد مضادات الطائرات من
قوات الدعم السريع
خروق كانت بشكل اساسي في نقاط حساسه مثل
محيط القياده العامه في الخرطوم والقصر
الرئاسي بالاضافه الى اندرمان وبحري
واقليم دارفور
هدن لا تبصر النور لم تكن اي منها مفتاحا
لفتح باب المفاوضات ووقف القتال في البلاد
ولم تنجح اي منها حتى في السماح بفتح
ممرات انسانيه لمساعده الاهالي باوضاعهم
المترديه اذا عمر العربيه
في السودان الاشتباكات تتواصل رغم الهدن
وضع انساني كارثي وتحذيرات دوليه من
الاسواق اما شرطه السودانيه باتت امام حد
اخر سببه التفلت الامني في البلاد اذ نظمت
حملات لمحاربه الجريمه بهدف بسط هيبه
الدوله وسياده حكم القانون الحملات شملت
في يومها الاول مناطق الفتاح العضليين
وسوق الدخينات وسوق الكلاكله اللفه مرورا
بابو ادم والعزوزاب وسوق الشجره بينما
نظمت الحمله في يومها الثاني في شارع
الشهيد ابراهيم شمس الدين ومنطقه السوق
الشعبي بالخرطوم وابو حمامه والمرافق
الحيويه اما حمله اليوم الثالث شملت مناطق
امتداد شارع الرميله مرورا بصك العمله
ومخازن السكر والمنطقه الصناعيه
الحملات حققت اهدافها المطلوبه بمشاركه
القوات المسلحه لتامين الاسواق والمناطق
التجاريه الهامه والمرافق الحيويه
ينضم الينا الصحفي عبد القادر باكاش اهلا
بك عبد القادر معنا في هذه الساعه
الاخباريه واترك لك المجال بدايه لتحدثنا
عن اوضاع المواطنين والرعايه الاجانب
الذين نزحوا الى بورسودان بغرض الاجلاء
22 ابريل
وتوقفت بالنسبه لاجلال المقيمين
السودانيين في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الان توقفت الايراد
نسبيا الان لاغراض فحص القوائم لان هناك
اجراءات امنيه يجب ان تتم بشان السودانيين
لكن بالنسبه للرعايه والاجانب الامل يلتزم
بشكل
تلقائي وممتاز جدا بالتنسيق مع السلطات
السعوديه الان
عمليات اجلال الامريكان والبريتانيين
والاستراليين وعموم الاوروبيين الان
بشكل جيد هناك سودانيين منشور اجنبيه
لديهم جنسيات امريكيه وبريطانيه ايضا تجري
اجراءاتهم ضمن الاخرين الان في فندق كوره
البورسودان بخصوص الوزن الانساني وصل وكيل
الامين العام لشؤون الانسانيه صباح اليوم
ومن المتوقع ان تصل طائره من نيبوبي
للشرير الاحمر ايضا خلال
الساعات القادمه والود
في مدينه بورسودان الان بدا يتفاهم خاصه
بعد التزايد اعداد القادمين من الخرطوم من
السودانيين والاجانب
يعني تاخر اجراءات الاجلاء التي كانت تمضي
بثلاثه خلال ايام الماضيه لكن الان نسبه
للتساعد او تزايد عدد السودانيين الراغبين
في الخروج ادى الى التدخل الستات لصاحب
بعض القوائم للوقوف على يعني سعه
الاجراءات اجراءات خروجهم من السودان تقول
ان الوضع بدا يتساقط في بورسودان الان
يعني يتفاقم من اي ناحيه
اللوائيه المدينه لم تحتمل هذه الاعداد
ولم تستعد لها لذلك شجر الفندقيه والفنادق
والمنازل والانديه والساحات جميعها الان
مكتزه برعايه اجانب وسودانيين يرغبون في
الخروج والادب يتزايد يوميا تيصل بالمعابر
البريه من الخرطوم عادات كبيره من
المواطنين السودانيين واجانب الراغبين في
الخروج الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه او
لوجهات اخرى الان اعداد السودانيين واعداد
للرعايه الاجانب الموجودين في مدينه
بورسلان عددهم بدات تتزايد وهناك ضغط على
الخدمات وهناك عادات كبيره من الاسر
والاشخاص الذين في الساحات وفي بحات
الفنادق وفي المساجد وفي ميادين وهناك
جنبيات خيريه ومنظمات محليه بدات تتبنى
تقديم بعد المساعدات لكن هجم الضغط عالي
جدا على مدينه بوران طيب عبد القادر
بعد متابعه مجموعه من الاخبار المتعلق
بالشان السوداني مشاهدينا يبدو ان الاوضاع
باتت ماساويه في دارفور ايضا حيث اكد مدير
جمعيته هلال الاحمر السوداني في غرب
دارفور ابو بكر محمد العربيه على ان كل
المستشفيات غرب دهر فور خرجت عن الخدمه
بسبب تدهور الوضع الامني واستمرار الحرب
وقال ان كل البنت تحتيه الصحيه بمدينه
الجنينه باتت منهاره
ولايه خربي دارفور تعرضت لكارثه كبيره جدا
جدا ادى الى تدمير كامل البنيه التحتيه
للمؤسسات بالاضافه لنظام الصحي بتاعه
الولايه بشكل كامل الان كل المستشفيات
خارج الخدمه هذا بعض المستشفيات
كفاءه ضعيفه جدا جدا فقط في الخيارات
بتاعه الخدمات بتاعه الاسعافات كل المخازن
الموجوده تم نهبها تماما ما في اي خدمات
موجوده بتاعه الخدمات الصحيه تماما الهلال
الاحمر السوداني الان يعمل
بصوره جيده منذ
خمس ايام بدانا بنخذ
من مناطق مختلفه
وفي تداعيات المواجهات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع في دار فورد اظهرت الصور واحتراق
اكبر سوق للبقوليات في نيالا عاصمه جنوب
حيث سقطت قذائف متبادله من طرفي الصراع ما
تسبب في خسائر كبيره بالاسواق التجاريه في
الاقليم
مع ذلك مع الناس الضيوف معنا الضيوف برضو
يقدروا بحوالي كم واربعين نفر دي كلها
عندهم فضائح حرقت في هذه المحل والله
200 جوال عدسيه
ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
المعطله بحاجه الحرب بين الان نحن برامج
ظروفك الخاصه
نعمل في هذه الظروف يعني صعبه وعدم
امكانيات اللي ما موجوده هنا
سحق بعض الادويه والمعدات
هو من اقليم مشاهدينا ينضم الينا الصحفي
صالح ابو علامه اهلا بك صالح معنا في هذه
الساعه الاخباريه وهل تجنح الاوضاع نحو
الهدوء ام التوتر في اقاليم دارفور هذه
اللحظه
نعم كان ينتظر من لجنه الوساطه التي تدخلت
بين طرفي الصراع في غرب دارفور المساليد
والقبائل العربيه بان تبدا اليوم العمل
بكل طاقتها لانزال الوثيقه على ارض الواقع
ولكن عندما تحدثنا اليها قالت ليله
الوساطه بان الوساطه تحتاج الى دعم رسمي
والى جهد رسمي
لمواصله العمل لذا يمضي العمل البطيء حتى
الان في غرب دارفور كان هنالك اتفاق مسبق
على نزول قوات الدعم السريع والاحتياط
المركزي الى سوق الجنينه الذي يتعرض الان
لعمليات سلب ونهب هنالك ما يقارب
الخمسمائه من المعتاديه الاجرام
والمتفلتين الان داخل السوق الجنينه
ينهبون ما تبقى من الاسواق وهنالك اتجاه
لنهب البنوك ايضا كما تحدثت الينا لجنه
الوساطه
قليل ليث الوساطه اتصلت بالمدير التنفيذي
لمحليه الجنينه
بان يعمل على اعانه قوات الاحتياط المركزي
بالوقود حتى يتسنى لها الدخول الى السوق
وبالفعل الان هي في طريقها الى سوق
الجنينه الدعم السريع
الذي يقف عمليه النهب في سوق الجنينه يعني
هل نتحدث
عن ربما مجموعات مسلحه او تعتبر ملابس
عسكريه
نعم هي مجموعات مسلحه ولكن لم ترصد
مجموعات مسلحه ترتدي ملابس عسكريه بكثره
في هذه الازمه وانما هنالك مجموعات مسلحه
اتت من خارج الجنينه الصراع هنا في دارفور
اصبحوا هنالك هجوم كبير على على اسواق
المدن المدن الكبيره خاصه العواصم
الولايات هنالك مجموعات تاتي من الخارج
مجموعات مسلحه تاتي من خارج المدينه من
المحليات المجاوره وتقتحم الاسواق وتنهب
كل ما بالاسواق تنهب البنوك وتذهب ايضا
المحلات التجاريه المخازن تنهب السيارات
وايضا تتعدى على المواطنين كل هذه هي
تداعيات الازمه السودانيه في ظل غياب
الامن في ظل غياب القوات التي تتحرك
لتامين المواطنين وتتحرك لتامين المنشات
خاصه هنالك التقاعس كبير جدا للادوار
الرسميه في بعض الاماكن في مدينه الجنينه
حتى الان ولولايه لم يخرج ولم يتحدث وايضا
لم نشهد ادوار رسميه كبيره في غرب دارفور
سوى المبادرات الشعبيه والمبادرات
الشبابيه التي تعمل ليل نهار من اجل اعاده
الوضع الى طبيعته في غرب دارفور حتى هنالك
مبادرات في اعاده الوضع الانساني لافضل
حالته هنالك علاج داخل الاحياء هنالك
كوادر تطوعت للعلاج العلاج المصابين في
مدينه الجنينه شبابيه لتشغيل
كبير سنعود لك في سياق النشاط المقبله من
اقليم مدار في الكتب معنا الصحفي صالح
وعلامه
الاف الفاري من الحرب السودانيه مشاهدينا
دخلوا الى جنوب السودان عبر معبر جوده
الجنوبي وضع انساني كارثي ومناشدات لتقديم
المسانده عبر هذا المعبر كاميرا العربيه
قابلت الفارين من السودان الى جنوب
السودان
اكثر من عشرين الف شخص هي جمله عدد
الفارين من الاشتباكات التي شهدها عدد من
المدن السودانيه خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين
دخلوا الى جنوب السودان عبر معبر جود
الجنوبي غالبيتهم من جنوب السودان والباقي
من جنسيات مختلفه
نحن من يوم 17 حتى يوم 30
سجلنا اجمالي عدد
2,826 اسره
وعدده
الجانب الفردي عشرين الف
و48
الاعداد لا تزال تزداد يوما بعد يوم في
الرحلات يرويها اصحابها بانها لا تخلو من
المعاناه والمخاطره
شفنا حاجات كثير في الشارع هي المتابعه
ولا في شنو ولا
حصل
عندنا خمسه هنا في جول الشمال كل حاجه كان
شايلينه في ايدينا تحت
وزير الشؤون الانسانيه الذي وصل الى معبر
جودا الجنوبي وصف الوضع الانساني بالكارثي
مناشدا المنظمات الانسانيه على تقديم
الدعم اللازم الوضع كارسي
والميزانيه في وقت ممكن ما يكفي عشان كده
بندي النداع
للمنظمات الانسانيه العالميه والمحليه اذا
في ظل هذه الاوضاع الانسانيه الحرجه تبقى
جوده معبرا يتطلع من خلاله الفارون
بالعبور الى المناطق الامنه داخل جنوب
السودان
الالاف من الحاربين من اتون الحرب التي
شهدتها عددا من المدن السودانيه عبروا الى
جنوب السودان عبر معبر جوده الجنوبيه وهم
يعدون العده بذهاب الى جبه او غيرها من
المدن الاخرى ولكن تذكره القبور تقف في
وجه الكثير منهم
العربيه
معبر جوده الجنوبيه
كشف سكرتيره نقابه اطباء السودان عطيه عبد
الله عطيه العربي عن وجود اكثر من 12 الف
مريض معرضون للموت بسبب الاوضاع الصحيه
وشددا على ضروره فتح ممرات امنه لايصال
الباعونات الطبيه عطيه يتحدث عن موت
مرضى داخل بيوتهم جراء الحرب
الاعداد في ازدياد شديد وهي متواليه
متوقعه بعد يعني تزايد العسكريه سوف يكون
هنالك اكثر من 12 الف مريض معرض للموت
الان نحن لدينا تقارير من ان هنالك عدد من
المرضى توفي داخل منازلهم
المياه في المستشفيات وفي المنازل يشكل
مشكله كبيره جدا في ظل عدم وصول هذه
المعينات سوف يتعرض 12 الف للموت نحن
قلناها وقررناها ان طرفي الصراع في
السودان تركوا الشعب السوداني امام خيارين
اما الموت بالرصاص او الموت بالمرض فقط
فتح ممرات امنه بالتاكيد سوف نصل الى هذه
المستشفيات سوف يستطيع الداعمين الوصول
وتوصيل معاناتهم بالتاكيد سوف يعني يتكاتف
الجميع في في هذه الازمه
تقرير لوزاره الصحه السودانيه كشف ايضا
تسجيل ست اصابات جديده بولايه الخرطوم
وحاله وفاه واحده بوضعيه وسط دارفور
ليقترب بذلك عدد الاصابات التراكمي من
خمسه الاف اصابه وخمسمائه وخمسين حاله
وفاه في جميع انحاء البلاد واوضح التقرير
ان الهدوء يسود كافه الولايات عدا ولايه
الخرطوم ووسط لكن الجهاز الطبي تواصل
تسجيل اصابات ووفيات نازجه الحرب القائمه
وفي محاوله لتخفيف اعباء القتال الداخلي
بين قوات الجيش والدعم السريع الذي يدوره
في السودان منذ اكثر من اسبوعين يخاطر
مستشفى خاص في ام درمان بفتح ابوابه لخدمه
النساء الحوامل واجراء عمليات الولاده دون
مقابل مادي وفي ظل ظروف امنيه وانسانيه
توصف بالكارثيه
بالمؤسسات الصحيه
يرافق استمرار القتال في السودان
لكن مستشفى خاصا في ام درمان
ينجح بفتح ابوابه لخدمه النساء الحوامل
مجانا
في ظل نادى من شبه كامل للامن
وارتفاع اثمان المستلزمات في السوق
السوداء
اكثر من عشره اضعاف السعر الحقيقي
320 عمليه ولاده قيصريه اجراها منذ اندلاع
القتال
فيما تقول نقابه الاطباء السودانيين ان
اكثر من 50 مستشفى بالخرطوم توقفت عن
العمل
وتحذيراته من انهيار القطع الصحي تتواصل
اليوم التاسع عشر تتواصل الجهود الدوليه
لوقف الحرب في السودان بين الجيش والدعم
السريع جهد تقودها عده جهات ابرزها الامم
المتحده ومنظمات مثل التعاون الاسلامي
ودول اقليميه مثل السعوديه ومصر
في هذا السياق احتضنت جده في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه اجتماعا طارئ لمناقشه
تطورات الاوضاع في السودان وذلك بناء على
دعوه من السعوديه التي تتراس القمه
الاسلاميه الحاليه واللجنه التنفيذيه
لمنظمه التعاون الاسلامي وافاد بيان
الصحفي بان المنظمه تدرس ارسال وفد رفيع
الى السودان بالتنسيق مع رئيس القمه
الاسلاميه واعرب الامين العام حسين
ابراهيم طه عن اسفه لوقوع هذه الاشتباكات
في وقت كان ينتظر فيه الجميع ان تتوج
محادثات الاطراف السودانيه باتفاق على
موعد جديد للتوقيع على اتفاق النهائي
هذا واكد مندوب السعوديه الدائم لدى منظمه
التعاون الاسلامي صالح السحباني ان
المملكه تبذل جهودا حثيثه لحل الازمه
السودانيه وانهاء الصراع واطالب السحباني
الاطراف السودانيه بوقف كافه اشكال
التصعيد لافتا الى مواصله القيام بدور
انساني ودبلوماسي كبير في الازمه كما شدد
على تطلع بلاده الى وقف دائم للاقتتال في
السودان وانخراط الاطراف في حواه من اجل
السلام هذا ودعا مندوب السعوديه خلال
اجتماع منظمه التعاون الاسلامي الى احترام
كافه البعثه الدبلوماسيه بالسودان والعمل
على توفير الحمايه لها
هذا ودان مجلس التعاون الخليجي على لسان
الامين العام المجلس ياسين البديوي اقتحام
الملحقي الثقافي السعوديه في الخرطوم وحذر
بما وصفه بالتصرفات التي تزيد مخاطر
انفلات الوضع في السودان ودع البداويه
جميع الاطراف الى اتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه
لحمايه الدبلوماسيين والمقرات الدبلوماسيه
مشاهدينا من القاهره معنا الصحفي المختصه
في الشان الافريقي صباح موسى اهلا بك سيدي
صباح معنا في هذه الساعه الاخباريه وكيف
تقرا الى المشهد في السودان على ضوء اليوم
التاسع عشر منذ بدء هذه المواجهات
البدايه تحياتي لكم استاذ احمد وتحياتي
للساده المشاهدين نحن في الاسبوع الثالث
وعلى مشارف نهاياتي وما زالت الامور بدات
تتضح اكثر فاكثر عمليات الهدن هي عمليات
اه الموافقه عليها سهله لكن
تنفيذها على ارض الواقع اصبح معروفا انها
لا تنفذ سهل جدا ان يوافق الطرفين على
الهدن ولكن اختراقها اصبح امر طبيعي داخل
السودان اعتقد ان المجتمع الدولي
والاقليمي بات يتاكد انه لابد من الالتفاف
حول هذه الحرب حتى لو كانت هناك تقاطعات
اقليميه ودوليه في السودان حتى لو كانت
هناك اطراف هي التي اجدت الحرب من خارج
السودان اعتقد انها وصلت لقناعه ان هذه
الحرب لن تصل الى شيء وانه لا يوجد طرف لن
يتغلب على الاخر صحيح ان الجيش السوداني
وفق معلومات من داخل السودان وشهود عيان
هو مسيطر وان الدعم السريع للاقاويل عليه
كثيره بانه يحتل المستشفيات وانه ياخذ
المدنيين رهائن هذا يعني
باقاويل لشهود عيان من داخل الخرطوم
وبالتالي الوضع الان يعني هناك مبادرات
كثيره مطروحه اكثرها اهميه اعتقد المبادره
السعوديه الامريكيه هناك اطراف تحاول ان
يعني تغذي معنى انه لابد من ان هذه
المبادره نهايتها هو حل سياسي اعتقد ان اي
حديث عن حل سياسي الان لابد ان يتنحى
جانبا نحن الان بصدد وقف اطلاق النار اولا
لكن في اعتقادي ايضا ان الطرف وخصوصا
القوات المسلحه هي تحاول ان تكسب وقت حتى
لو لم تتغلب في المعركه هي تريد ان يعني
تضعف كثيرا قوات الدعم السريع حتى عندما
تقع تجلس على طاوله ستجلس اولا لجوانب
انسانيا ثانيا لوقف اطلاق نار ومن ثم
ثالثا يعني الثقه بين الطرفين كما تفضلت
يعني هناك حراك اقليمي ودولي كبير لكن
السؤال هنا اين هي الجامعه العربيه بما
يحدث في السودان هل ترين في غيابها عن لعب
دور فاعل في هذه الازمه امرا طبيعيا في ظل
تنامي الادوار التي تلعبها دول عربيه اخرى
خارج نطاله الجامعه
دائما الجامعه العربيه بتكون منخرطه بقى
مع بدايات الازمات بالبيانات وبالاحاديث
التي لو نفذت على ارض الواقع سيكون لها
تاثير لكن هو هي طبيعه الجمعه العربيه
بتنخرط منذ بدايه الازمه وهي موجوده
وفاعله لكن للاسف الشديد الجماعه دايما
ليس لديها اليه لتنفيذ تصريحاتها
وبياناتها على الارض حتى منذ بدايه اشتعال
الازمه كانت هي اول يعني كانت اول الذين
خرجوا يرفضون وتنادي بوقف اطلاق النار لكن
اين هي الاليه يعني دعى الامين العام بانه
من الممكن ان يذهب الى الخرطوم وبالتاكيد
من الصعب جدا الوصول الى الخرطوم في هذا
التوقيت لعدم التامين وبالتالي اعتقد ان
الجميع العربيه فاعليتها
كمنظمه لم تكون مؤثره على ارض الواقع
الدول الاعضاء في الجامعه العربيه
كالسعوديه كمصر كالامارات بشكل منفرد
اعتقد من الممكن ان يكون لها تاثير اكثر
لما لهم من واختراق في المشهد السياسي
السوداني فطبيعه الجامعه العربيه اصلا في
كل الازمات سوريا وليبيا
واليمن وكل الازمات العربيه هي حاضره
وموجوده لكن حاضره بالشكل النظري ليست
لديها اليات حاسمه على الارض لتحسن مثل
هذه النزاعات
يعني هل تعتمد على علاقات حسن الجوار
للتعاطي مع الطرفين ام انها في تقديرك
تمتلك كروت ضغط يمكن ان ترغمهما بها على
الاستجابه لهذه التهدئه
بالتاكيد القاهره طبعا انت تعلم وضع
الحساسيه في العلاقات مع السودان لكن
القاهره تعمل على قدم وساق منذ الاشتباكات
حتى انها دائما تنصف مع الدول الاقليميه
والدوليه التي لها كروت ضغط على طرفي
النزاع ايضا هي من يعني هي من المستحيل ان
نقول ان القاهره ليس لديها قروض ضغط لديها
كروت ضغط ولابد ان يكون لديها كروت ضغط
لان ما يحدث في السودان هو بشكل اساسي
يشكل يعني خطر بالغ على امنها القومي
وبالتالي فكره ان القاهره هي دائما
القاهره عندما تتحرك في الموقف السوداني
بالذات تتحرك بشكل فعلي على الارض لا تعلن
عن تحركاتها لكن في الاخير هي يعني تثمر
هذه التحركات الى يعني اجراءات فاعله
واعتقد ان القاهره قريبا جدا مع يعني دول
اقليميه ودوليه ستصل الى حل في السودان ان
شاء الله شكرا لكم يا القاهره كنت معنا
الصحفيه المختصه في الشان الافريقي صباح
موسى تحيه سيده صباح
في ملف الاجلاء مشاهدينا اعلنت الخارجيه
السعوديه عن عدد من تم اجلائهم من السودان
حتى الان والذي بلغ
5,629 شخصا من رعايه اكثر من 100 جنسيه
وقالت الخارجيه السعوديه ان عدد المواطنين
الذين تم اجلائهم من السودان بلغ 239
اخرهم وصل مساء الثلاثاء على مدن سفينه
جلاله الملك الرياض الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه في جده
اتواجد حاليا على متن سفينه جلاله الملك
الرياض وهي الرحله الخامسه عشر منذ بدا
عمليات الاجلام من ميناء بورتسودان الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحري سوف ناخذكم في
جوله خاصه لشاشه العربيه كما نشاهد الان
بدات عمليات الانزال بعد ان وصلت هذه
السفينه من ميناء بورت سودان في رحله
استغرقت قرابه العشره الساعات من ميناء
بورت سودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده على متن هذه السفينه 220 راكبا من
خمسه جنسيات
نتحدث عن 91 من الجنسيه الامريكيه و14
مواطن السعودي وثلاثه كنديين واثنان من
جنوب السودان وواحد من الجنسيه السودانيه
ايضا نتحدث انه اعداد كبيره تصل الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده منذ بدء عمليات
الاجلاء خلال الايام الماضيه نتحدث عن
ارقام اجم تتجاوز الخمسه الاف
مواطن اجنبي من مئه جنسيه تم اجلائهم من
ميناء بورسودان الى جده عبر قاعه الملك
فيصل البحريه او حتى الى قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه وكذلك الى ميناء جده الاسلامي
اعداد كبيره من الرعايه يتوافدون يوما بعد
يوم وتزداد الاعداد بشكل ملحوظ مع عمليه
مع كل عمليات اجلاء ايضا ومتوقع وصول
سفينه مدنيه تجاريه سعوديه على متنها
اعداد تلامس الفين شخص يوم
ظهر يوم غد
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه في
افاده صحفي امس قال ان القنصليه الامريكيه
في مدينه جده السعوديه استقبلت وقدمت
خدماتها لاكثر من 350 شخصا من المواطنين
الامريكيين والحاصلين على اقامات دائمه في
الولايات المتحده والذين افرهم الى
السودان في ظل الاوضاع العسكريه الراهنه
التي تشهدها البلاد
بدورها قالت الحكومه البريطانيه في بيان
ان على الرعايه البريطانيين الراغبين في
مغادره السودان التوجه الى فندق كورال
حيث من المتوقع ان تغادر رحلات اضافيه
بلاد اليوم
اعلن المغرب من جهه نهايه عمليات الاجلاء
للمواطنين المغاربه من السودان حيث تم
اجلاء
50072 شخصا على متن اربع رحلات جويه
على سلام والحمد لله كله عن طريق السفاره
وجزاهم الله خير والله ينصر سيدنا والحمد
لله على سلامتنا اقول الله يحفظ ملكنا
وربنا يديه طوله العمر ان شاء الله احنا
طلعنا من حاجه
جهنم شعور زوين الحمد لله على سلامه
الجميع والحمد لله الاحساس بالامان الحمد
لله على كل شيء
ساعه يعني واحنا جايين في الكار عاد وصلنا
ان شاء الله للطياره وجينا الحمد لله بخير
وكل شيء يعني داز امن والحمد لله على خير
احنا فرحانين منين وصلنا للمغرب وصلنا
بسلام فرحانين الحمد لله
وكنشكروا سيدنا زعما اللي بدر معنا هكا
وقف معانا
وتوصلنا المغرب في امان
طلعت من البيت كان تقريبا الساعه عشره
طلعت ما فيش ولا ركشه ولا مواصله وسيارات
بس بتعدي فش حدا بيوقف لك وكان ورا البيت
فيه زي في المنطقه الصناعيه محروقه فكان
نفس الدخان شغال فيعني عنجد حسيت في انه
يعني رعب هو كان في شعور يعني خوف
ورعب يعني انك تشوف جوتك مرميه يمين يسار
وناس مقطعه
والبنوك محروقه يعني بتحسي انه خلاص بطل
في امان نهائي ومستقبل وقف
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات